well the government has so far spent 200
billion pounds tackling the pandemic and
today the chancellor has promised
another
three billion pounds for the nhs and in
deciding which restrictions will be in
place throughout december
the government will be balancing the
health of the economy with the health of
the nation
or joining us now is the man who's got
those very difficult decisions to make
the chancellor
rishi sunai thank you very much for
being on the programme this morning at
mr sunak
and i just want to start off with a
question that so many of our viewers
will want to
know the answer to this morning will
families be able to meet up at christmas
well the prime minister will be setting
out more details tomorrow
sophie about the next steps in our fight
against chronovirus i think the good
news is we will be exiting national
restrictions
on the 2nd of december as the prime
minister said at the beginning
of the month-long restrictions we'll be
going back into a tiered system
which is a far better way to tackle this
on a localized approach
and with regard to christmas you know i
think frustrating as it is for all of us
christmas is not going to be
normal this year but that said the prime
minister and everyone else were looking
at ways to see how families
can spend some time with each other over
christmas period obviously that's
something that we would like to do
and it's been a difficult year for all
of us but it's as i said
it's not going to be a normal christmas
this year and public health england
said this week that for every day the
restrictions are relaxed over christmas
we could need five days of tighter
restrictions
as a result we just heard from professor
callum semple earlier on the program who
said he thought
that was about right so if we ease
restrictions for christmas
we're going to be paying for it in
january aren't we
well i think as a deputy chief medical
officer spoke about this just the other
day i think it's
it's difficult to be so precise uh
and granular about the impact of any
individual
uh measure that we might take um but
that's why i said
it's not going to be a normal christmas
this year i think the good news is we're
going to be exiting national
restrictions which is something that
people
i think at the beginning of this were
doubtful of we said that was
very much what we wanted to deliver we
are going to deliver that
prime minister will be setting out more
details tomorrow about going back to a
more localized approach
seeing what we can do to allow families
to see each other
um at christmas time but it is not going
to be normal
if it's not going to be normal what are
you what changes are you going to be
making this christmas
well i mean i wait uh with everyone else
we'll see what the prime minister
sets out this week about what we're
going to be able to do and we'll go from
there but i think
fundamentally i think you know with
christopher ultimately a time for us to
be together with our own family so
that that will always be able to be the
case and depending on how many other
people we're able to see is what we'll
need to see what we can do
but you know we must we've put a lot of
work in over the past month it's been
enormous sacrifice on everyone's part
and we want to make sure that we
continue suppressing the virus the good
news is that we've made
improvements whether it's in mass
testing or early promising news on
vaccines
that should give us all hope that there
are other ways to suppress the spread of
the virus as we go through winter
and so we can get what you know get to
the target that we all want which is
more of our lives and our economy
back to normal now you've mentioned
already of course that we're going to be
leaving
the lockdown in england on the 2nd of
december and going into this new
strengthened
tier system so in what way is the tier
system going to be strengthened
well the prime minister will set out
more details of that tomorrow
what we want to do is constantly adapt
and evolve as we gain more information
about the virus and you know every week
every day that goes
uh goes we go through this we get more
data we can see what's working
what's the most effective way to tackle
the spread of this whilst minimizing the
restrictions
on people's freedom and and that's and
that's what we do so
on the basis of the advice we get from
our medical and scientific advisors
looking at everything in the round see
how we can fine-tune things
uh as i said to make sure that what
we're doing is as effective as it can be
so i'm very keen as well as many
businesses
will be keen to know the rules about
what will happen for
shops pubs restaurants businesses for
whom
christmas period is absolutely critical
many of them already on the brink
three-quarters of a million people
already lost their jobs
since the start of this crisis don't
these businesses need to be given a
fighting chance of survival
by being allowed to trade in december
well look you're absolutely right to
highlight all the things that you just
did it's a tragedy that three quarters
of a million people have already lost
their jobs
you know that's millions of families and
people who are impacted
by that and it's a difficult time for
everyone and you're right about the
stress that businesses are under
particularly in the sectors that you
mentioned
you know that's why we've provided the
enormous amount of support
to protect people's jobs protect their
livelihoods and to try and support
business through what
is a very difficult period and you
mentioned hospitality
you know that's one area where we've
tried to do a lot whether it's cutting
vat
providing cash grants special loans
uh all of these things are trying to
help that industry get through a
difficult period
uh and and you're absolutely right those
are the kind of things that we need to
balance
yes we're tackling a health crisis but
it has lots of impacts on other aspects
of our lives and we need to take all of
those things in the round when we make
these decisions
um i just want to talk to you about a
letter that's just been published
by the covid recovery group of
conservative
70 mps in that group a letter to the
prime minister
and they want the government to publish
the full cost benefit
analysis of the tier system of lockdown
they say we cannot support this approach
unless the government demonstrates the
restrictions proposed after the 2nd of
december
will save more lives than they cost
today the lockdown cure prescribed
runs the very real risk of being worse
than the disease
what's your reaction to that and will
you publish the full cost-benefit
analysis
well i think i've i've spoken about the
economic side of this many times and
what i'd say is
you know i think it's as i just said
previously when we're having the
conversation it's right that we look at
all of the impacts of fighting
coronavirus in the round
and and they're not just economic
obviously there are job losses and
because
you publish the cost benefit analysis
well i say on the economic side as i've
said it's very hard to be precise
and estimating the particular impact of
a one-week restriction
have some estimates done though surely
but but what i mean what you will see
next week when we have the spending
review alongside that will be
a set of forecasts from the office for
budget responsibility the independent
forecasting and fiscal watchdog we have
in this country which will show
the enormous strain and stress that our
economy is experiencing the job losses
that you
mentioned the forecast for what will
happen and it's right that we think
about those
in the round as we consider the best way
to fight the virus
okay and now i just want to read you a
letter
uh or a message that i was sent from a
viewer called chris who
asked me to ask something of you i've
received many of these
before the interview with you and chris
says
please ask rishi sunak about the people
excluded from government support
please don't accept his usual response
of well we've done lots to help those
people over there and ignore the
question
it's the equivalent of your house
burning down and the fire brigade
claiming they've done a good job because
they sprayed water on next door
meanwhile
you're left with no home what can you
say to chris
well first i'm sorry to hear that chris
is going through a difficult time like
many others
through this crisis i have every
sympathy for him now it's difficult for
me without knowing his particular
circumstances what we might
have done that would be of benefit to
him which is why i have to talk slightly
in generalities but
if he's self-employed i'd probably say
i'm confident in knowing that the
support we've provided
director if that helps it's more it's
more comprehensive and generous than
pretty much any other country
between three and a half and four
million people have been eligible
for that support uh which has gone out
in various tranches and will continue
through the winter and you know be
beyond the direct support for the
self-employed
we've made lots of other changes here
and there that may help him whether it's
offering discounted loans whether it's
strengthening our
welfare system help with people's
mortgages or council tax payments
you know so i'm confident that we've
done an enormous amount that said
i know of course that there will be
people who will feel they haven't got
the help they want in exactly the way
they want
but as i said we are always trying to do
what we can to provide support to people
through the winter and and throughout
this crisis
okay well let's talk about the
all-important spending review shall we
um
you're announcing an extra three billion
pounds for the nhs to help people
who've had their treatment delayed by
the pandemic is this an admission that
non-covered patients have been let down
well i think this is about one of the
impacts that we were just talking about
sophie when you asked
about the other impacts of restrictions
and this is what happened earlier
on you know we know we've got a backlog
of people who have missed
whether it's mental health treatments or
elective surgery or scans
so what we're doing is investing 3
billion pounds into the nhs
next year to help them make a start on
tackling that
this will provide enough funding to do a
million
uh treatment scans surgeries to make a
start on tackling that backlog
a lot of that is also for for mental
health treatments that have been missed
um and it's right that we do that but as
it as you rightly point out
what this illustrates is one of the
other costs of what we've had to do to
tackle coronavirus alongside the
economic costs
you'll also of course be laying out that
an economic cost
and talking about the state of the
public finances which we both know is
going to be a pretty
sobering read three quarters of a
million people have lost their jobs
during the pandemic
and national debt is more than two
trillion pounds that's bigger than the
entire uk economy of gdp borrowing is at
its highest
level since records began
how have we ended up with what seems to
be the worst of all worlds a wrecked
economy
and the highest clover death toll in
europe
well i think look when it comes to the
economic impact
in common with many other countries
we're seeing a significant impact this
year
now you know one thing that is
particular about our economy
is social activities you know for
example the ones we've been talking
about going out having a meal seeing
people
they comprise a slightly larger share of
our economy
than they do for other countries
obviously that's the part of our economy
that's had the most impact of all of
this so it's unsurprising that we're
seeing
uh the results that we are you know the
initial lockdown we had
in duration was longer than other
countries that will of course
uh have had an impact as well and i
think slightly more
technically um but still i think a point
of worthy of node is the way in which we
calculate
impacts on gdp is slightly different to
other countries and i
need to probably go into it in detail
here but there's a way we calculate
activity in the public sector is
different which means that some of our
numbers
may actually look a lot worse when you
compare them to other countries but on a
genuinely
comparable basis they wouldn't quite be
a starker difference but i said look
no one is pretending that has not been a
significant impact on our economy
there has that's why we have stepped in
to provide the support to protect
millions of jobs and people's
livelihoods
and business as best we can through this
period so what are you going to
do uh from wednesday onwards to try and
rebalance
and deal with the public the finances
are you looking at tax cuts are you
looking at sorry tax risers should i say
spending cuts or both well
next week is about spending review which
is it's more focused on providing
spending budgets for departments next
year and because of the uncertainty
that we're experiencing at the moment we
took the decision to make that just a
one-year spending review
so most departments will see their
budgets rolled over and that's because
our primary focus at the moment is
rightly on responding to coronavirus so
providing the funds we need for the
health response whether that's
test and trace mass testing vaccines the
nhs
or indeed protecting people's jobs
businesses and livelihoods
as we've talked about that's the
priority for next week but you will also
see us
getting on with delivering on what we
were elected to do which is invest in
public services
and invest in infrastructure around the
country to level up spread opportunity
and help drive our economic recovery
one of your biggest challenges as
chancellor if not the biggest challenge
is going to have to
chart a way forward for the economy
after this
huge economic shock that has happened
and there's been lots of reports about a
proposed and planned
public sector pay freeze frances o'grady
was on just before you talking about why
she thinks that would be
a really bad idea and of course many of
these workers that she was talking about
people like
teachers refuse collectors prison
officers these are people who've been
working
on the front line during lockdown
you and the prime minister have both
said you don't want to return to
austerity but for many of these people
the hallmark of austerity
was seeing a pay freeze so if it looks
like austerity if it sounds like
austerity
if it feels like austerity then it is
austerity isn't it
well i i don't think that's fair
characterization at all and first of all
you know
i've worked with francis closely uh
during this crisis on various things so
very much
you know listen to what she has to say
and respectfully disagree in some
in some areas i think you will not see
austerity next week what you will see
is an increase in the government
spending on day-to-day public services
you know quite a significant one coming
on the increase that we had last year so
i think there's absolutely no way in
which anyone could say
uh that's austerity we're spending more
money on public services
uh than we were and then you know with
regard i can't comment on
future pay policy in advance of the
spending review but what i would say
is when we when we launched the spending
review i did say to departments that
when we think about public safe
settlements i think it would be entirely
reasonable to think about those in the
context of the wider economic climate
i think that's a reasonable thing to do
and then also secondly
i think it would be fair and francis i
think use the word fairness as well i
think it would it would be fair to also
think about what's happening with wages
with jobs with hours
across the economy when we think about
what the right thing to do
in the public sector is so listening to
the end part of that answer
are you considering a pay freeze for
public sector workers
as i said so if you i can't comment in
advance of pay policy being set at the
spending review and i'll just point you
to this you're not ruling it out
when we when we launch i mean you can
ask me any question and say are you
ruling out ruling it in
i mean those are the the points i made
you know we were talking
you are also talking about fairness and
you said that you're looking at wages
and you're looking at what would be the
right thing to do there
as i said yes when we launched a
spending review we said when we think
about public sector pay
with that should be done in the context
of the overall economic climate i think
that's an entirely reasonable
uh thing to do and also as francis also
talked about
fairness as as we discussed you know we
need to see what's going on with wages
with jobs with employment with hours
across the economy when we calibrate and
figure out what the best thing to do for
public sector is as well
your manifesto at the last election said
we will not raise the rate of income tax
vat
or national insurance so are you going
to stick to that promise and if you are
does that mean that you're going to have
to at some point look at other taxes
such as
potentially capital gains tax
so if i you know as you whenever i'm on
here and you try and ask me these things
i'm sorry i have to give you the same
answer i can't comment on
future fiscal policy uh for all the
obvious
reasons and i think it's probably right
for people to remember the next week is
a spending review it's not
uh it's not a budget and in the spending
what we're doing is setting out the
department's budgets
for next year and as i said what you'll
see is more investment in day-to-day
public services
getting on with our manifesto investing
in infrastructure to spread opportunity
around the country drive our recovery
but primarily the focus will be on
fighting coronavirus
so funding for our health response and
also protection for people's jobs and
their livelihoods
through this crisis that's our focus and
it should be our focus at this time
um i've got a feeling that i might get a
similar answer to this next question but
i am going to want to ask it anyway
because i think it's so important to
so many people across the country the
government increased
universal credit by 20 pounds a week
because of
the coronavirus pandemic but that's due
to end
next april according to the joseph
roundary foundation that could push
700 000 people including 300 000
children into poverty are you looking at
extending that
well what i'd say is you're absolutely
right and that was one of the steps that
we took at the beginning of this crisis
it was one of a number of things we did
to provide support to
people you know through through the
acute phase of this crisis
it runs all the way to april as you as
you said and
you know so there's no need to make a
decision on it now many of the things
that we've put in place whether
it's furlough or the others they run
through the winter into the spring
and we keep everything under review and
we'll make the decisions that are right
for the economy
i think one thing we know and have
learnt this virus is
adapting evolving our ability to combat
it is adapting and evolving
so there's an enormous amount of
uncertainty at the moment and it
wouldn't be right to make long-term
decisions
right now but of course as we get
through and we'll have
future events like budgets where we can
take stockholm and see what's the right
way
both to support the economy but
importantly to support people
in their jobs in employment and support
businesses as we try and hopefully
emerge from this and get back to growing
again there's also been a lot of
speculation about
what's going to happen with foreign aid
it's going to read what your manifesto
said
we will proudly maintain our commitment
to spend 0.7
of gross national income on development
are you going to stick to that promise
again you know
we've got a spending review on on
wednesday where we'll talk about all the
budgets
i'm asking about your manifesto in an
election that was just last year
yeah and and you're right to read that
out and you and i am proud of our
commitment and i think we've seen that
in the in the last few months and we've
played i think a leading role
in helping to combat this uh pandemic
not just at home but also abroad as well
whether it's helping to provide
vaccines to other countries using the
brilliance of our researchers here to
get treatments to places around the
world
so lots of different ways that we've
demonstrated leadership and made a
difference
uh to some of the world's poorest
countries at what has been a very
difficult time and
that will never you know that will that
will never stop whilst we're
whilst we're in government okay um
just finally if the minister breaks the
ministerial code
should they remain a minister well
you'll know that the prime minister is
the ultimate arbiter of the ministerial
code that's how it's set out
and the prime minister is the one that
will make that judgment
on a case-by-case basis and i think
obviously you'll be
asking i'm sure about the home secretary
the prime minister's reviewed
the findings of the independent advisor
has come to the
conclusion that he has and the home
secretary has rightly offered her a full
and unreserved apology
and and the promise said that that as
far as he's concerned means that the
matter should be
you know put a line under and we should
move on and i'm glad to hear that the
culture has improved in the home office
and we're getting back to
doing what people want us to do which is
focus on keeping their streets safe
fighting crime um good to say that
things have improved at the home office
after people found out what was
happening there before and you say the
prime minister is the ultimate arbiter
of the ministerial code
but for many people that's kind of the
issue that they're worried about
and because you can see why some might
question whether he's approached this
from a neutral perspective
in march when the inquiry was launched
so well before
it found anything out he said that
pretty patel was doing an
outstanding job and i have every
confidence in her i am sticking by her
that's before the conclusions
according to whitehall sources when the
report was published he tried to water
it down and then
he asked conservative mps to form a
square around the pritster
is there one rule for boris johnson or
is there one rule
for friends of boris johnson and another
rule for everyone else
well look there was a review conducted
by an independent
advisor that and the findings of that
review have been published
and as the system works it's right that
the prime minister
as the person who is in charge and runs
a government
is able to receive that report go
through the findings and make a decision
that he thinks is right weighing up all
the considerations
you know that that's what he's done the
home secretary has offered a full and
unreserved apology
for what's happened and i think at that
point you know we we can move on
and it's a focus on the things that
people want us to do which is keeping
their streets safe and that's what the
home secretary is doing that's what the
government
is doing i can understand why and the
government might want to move on for
from this but it does feel that there
may be still questions to answer on it
the report from the government's now
former advisor on standard said
my advice is that the home secretary has
not consistently met the high standards
required by the ministerial code
her approach on occasions has amounted
to behavior that can be described
as bullying so on what basis has the
prime minister reached a different
conclusion
well i think the prime minister's
reviewed everything and has come
to the conclusion that he has and he
doesn't believe that a different
conclusion
is and respectfully it is a different
conclusion he doesn't believe the home
secretary
is a bully but the home secretary has
offered a full and unreserved
uh apology for what's happened and
i think at that point you know the
finest has made his decision and we
should get back to focusing on on what
people
on people what people want okay uh rishi
cena we are
out of time but thank you very much for
coming on the program ahead of such a
busy week
for you thank you